also i think as a woman in the workplace
as a young woman i had to almost like
pretend to not be
a woman and not be feminine and just
ignore that identity
and so all of a sudden i was like at a
concert and i just like
had somatic experiences i was like oh
i'm feeling the music in my body i'm
like there's information
here there's a gut feeling
kareem karmi welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you today
amazing thank you so much for having me
it's a pleasure no no
the honor is mine and the pleasure is
mine uh because i'm always excited to
dive into a whole new industry and a
whole new market that i i know
absolutely nothing about but
but i want to know more about before we
dive into what you're doing with origen
i i'd love to go back a little bit
through upend researcher and you're
getting your bachelor's degree there and
you go on to do all sorts of interesting
stuff whether it's with 3d printing
or or b or being a vp at shapeways
instructor general assembly vp
sales at amino all sorts of different
weird things taking me a little bit
through your journey
origin yeah
i'm happy too and you know i think the
common thread is just like follow your
curiosity right because you never know
where the world is going to take you but
um i i grew up in la and i i went to
school on the east coast at penn
undergrad
and um it was a really actually amazing
experience um
loved it there and i thought i was gonna
be a journalist and then you know after
a lot of pressure from family and also
you know
kind of seeing the business side i was
like okay this is actually very
compelling um so
instead of econ and i graduated actually
into the 2008 recession
so that was something special and you
know definitely feel for everyone who's
graduating
this year mid covet i know it's you know
crazy crazy times but
um i was lucky enough to be able to get
a job in management consulting and this
was 2008
um like the week before i joined they
let us know that they had let go
you know 20 percent of the firm so i'm
kind of like holding onto my chair like
okay what is this world's gonna be
um and it was just an amazing boot camp
you know i think
there's various ways you can start your
career i just feel really grateful to
be in a position where my job literally
every day was learn as much as i can as
quickly as possible and like you know
provide the best advice we can i'm using
data and you know analytics and
it was a good boot camp um but about a
few years in
i started really developing my passion
for
technology and digital media and i
actually remember
i saw this one video that came out of
the mit media lab and it was called the
sixth sense and it was you know the
early days of ar vr and i was like this
is the coolest thing i've ever seen i
have to work in tech
um and i was like i don't have any
skills but i got to work in this
industry
um and we had a digital media
kind of consulting arm of monitor called
market space and they were actually
spinning out the practice into its own
like kind of digital consulting
studio and so i kind of just knocked on
their doors it was three partners i was
like you gotta take me with you i'm
coming
um so uh we started a boutique um
digital media firm called market space
next for a few years
um and it was amazing so you know i went
from like fifty thousand feet to ten
thousand feet and
um we did everything from you know like
go to market strategies and ux design
and you know you just kind of
make it up as you go along but it was a
great learning experience um
and both of my parents are small
business owners
so i'd always thought about kind of
doing the startup thing and i
new york at the time like the new york
tech scene was you know maybe 10 000
people it was really small in 2009
um the the tech meetup was like the
literal event that everyone would go to
and so i just started applying to jobs
and it took me about a year and a half
to actually get someone to believe in me
that you know this person who had like
no real operational skills um
i basically this is like the pro tip i i
wrote a blog post
about 3d printing because i thought it
was a really interesting category
and then i sent it to the ceo of the
company shapeways um which was hiring
for a head of marketing and i
i just was like you know i know it
doesn't look like it on paper but like
just take me i promise you it's not
gonna be a bad
a bad thing um and it was really one of
the best career
moves i was able to make um we were
really small at the time
this is when 3d printing was just taken
off and um i got to join the team really
early days and help hope like
just build this category and it was so
fun because you know 3d printing is much
bigger now but
at the time it was all of these like
really passionate designers
all around the world making products in
ways that they've never been able to do
before so it felt like we were really
democratizing
manufacturing and creation and i learned
a lot
i made a lot of mistakes you know i
definitely had my like first office cry
where i was like i don't know how to do
seo what does this mean like i can't
learn all of this like today
um but it was an amazing experience and
i got to go from you know first marketer
to leading our marketing team and then
over time building out
our marketing community e-commerce teams
and um you know
felt really lucky to have people believe
in me too because you know you just
there's hard work but you also have to
have the right leadership to kind of
cease physio um so that was that was a
good boot camp made a lot of mistakes
but it was really fun
um and then i was thinking about moving
to california you know kind of the
the pull from home kept uh kept pulling
and
um had always been interested in health
care and we had done a lot of healthcare
work at monitor and at market space
um and this was when you know digital
health has like kind of started to grow
as a category and you start to see more
innovative direct to consumer and
and just innovative models and how we
improve the health care system
and i i decided to stop being skeptical
and believe that like you could change
healthcare and so
um i joined an amazing founder david
vivero
at a company called amino um which is
now one of the leading providers of kind
of
navigating the healthcare system and
financial wellness around healthcare
um because like today it's still i mean
you know this
you know with healthcare in the us it's
crazy most people can't even afford a
surprise medical bill and the difference
between walking to like urgent care and
er
is just insane um and there's no price
transparency there's no quality
transparency so we're really trying to
tackle that
um and go ahead we're gonna say
something i i just um i keep
going back to this experience it was my
first week at stanford one of the
economics professors
that i had was talking about this the
fact that
most americans can't pay us a 400 bill
if their car breaks down in the middle
of the street
which which to me you know it was it was
unbelievable it was unfathomable to
imagine that
that the majority of the of of us
families can't afford a 400
emergency and what does that mean about
a broken financial system where
and you know there's totally consumer
spending on one hand
but lack of information understanding
about you know rational decision making
but sorry that's my digression go ahead
no
i'm look i'm with you and we can have a
whole conversation around equity in this
country and i think that's been
for me one of the biggest kind of pull
points because at amino and even with
shapeways it's like
you shouldn't have this asymmetric
either power information
or even you know financial tools and
even the same is true in women's health
but
you know that that reality of just how
deeply uneducated most americans myself
included are about you know how health
care works like what is a deductible
it's you know we're kind of hiding or
the system hides behind these
complicated words and systems but it
truly has
you know a major impact on the
livelihood of individuals and that you
know
impacts their work and you see now in
covid so many people are afraid of
losing their jobs not just because of
losing their jobs but losing health care
and so like this whole system
you know fundamentally needs to change
but politics aside
um you know we we were able to grow the
team and the business
a lot and and ultimately we pivoted from
a direct assume consumer um
company to b2b and that's when i helped
build out our sales team and
kind of customer success and as you
could probably tell throughout my career
i was like i want to do more i want to
learn more and like i really loved you
know
seeing all aspects of the business like
i love marketing but for me that was
just the entry point
um and so i'll never forget you know a
few years into amino um
the founder david took me to lunch he
was like korean i've ever thought about
being a ceo
and i was like honestly no like i never
put that on my radar and just like that
conversation
opened up this possibility for me and so
i'm eternally grateful to david he's
honestly the best person i've worked
with
in my career and it was that moment
where
as we started moving to b2b i you know
i'm not the best like enterprise sales
leader in the country like the team and
the company needed someone else i was
living between two cities and just we
all decided it was best if i
transitioned out so i took some time off
um
which was the most terrifying thing i'd
ever done but i highly recommend it
to anyone you know in their kind of like
early mid-career if you don't know it's
you know it's really helpful to get that
clarity and i started working with a
coach
and just did like a lot of that personal
exploration that
i had never stopped to do you know
graduating at 21 i was like go go go and
i was like wait who am i and
what i want to actually do with my life
and um i think on a personal note
i i felt this like oh go ahead i i
really want to pause at that
uh at that break and the finding the
time
because i know but i'm both feeling it
myself that this rush and this
you know need to to embrace every
opportunity possible
especially given that you know if we
come with a place where we do have a
privilege to have those opportunities
it's
it's very hard for me to you know sleep
an extra hour if i know that i could be
meeting somebody like you
and and have a show like this but talk
to me a little bit about this decision
to take some time off work with a coach
understand a little bit about yourself
how old were you and and and what was
actually going on
during that time yeah so i
was um 2018 i'm 34 now so a couple years
ago i was you know like 32 or 31 at the
time
um and no 32. yeah i can't do math it's
cool whatever anyways early 30s and um
it was it was terrifying honestly i
actually so i got
married my husband was in la i was
living in san francisco i flew back
after the wedding and i had a breakdown
in shavasana in yoga and i was like what
the hell am i doing like what is my life
right now you know and
i i'm like crying on the like on the
yoga mat and the woman's like are you
okay i'm like i'm fine like i can't
i just can't feel right now um and and
it
you know i loved the team at origins at
amino so much and i'd like you know you
orient your life around companies when
you're in the startup world and
and i think that's amazing and i don't
regret it but i also
i wasn't at that point the right fit for
that role anymore and i was like okay so
so now what and so i had this moment
where i said like i can either go jump
into a new job
and like the money-making person to me
is like okay let's go do that
um but i know that if i had gotten to
that point where i was work i was so
misaligned with my myself and my goals
like whatever i was going to do next i
was just going to be in the same place
a few years later um and so i actually
i called it like i needed a spiritual
chiropractor it's like i need to just
get back into alignment and figure out
who am i and what do i value and how do
i get my life to reflect that and not
just get stuck on this pole because i
think especially in silicon valley are
these big cities where
um there's a lot of very prominent
models of success you could just think
that that's what it's supposed to look
like for you
um and and i think for a lot of people
it's great but you know let's let's not
let's let's ride our own train you know
we don't need to like get pulled by
by the the examples that have been
pulled before us
um so i spent a lot of money on a coach
um
it was like terrifying it was like i'm
unemployed and i'm like spending
thousands of dollars on working with
this person
best decision i made in my life um like
i actually met with her a couple of
weeks ago around my birthday and i was
like
can you imagine like we were sitting
there with a white board and i was like
i have no idea and now
i'm managing a 28-person team like you
know venture funded this whole thing i'm
like how's this you know this is crazy
um and in a space that's so important to
me but was like not even present at the
time
um so it like it took a lot of work and
i think
for me it was obviously very much around
like
you know what do i value and how do i
think about my criteria for what's next
but it was also about um actually like
the mental health sides of things
because i think what was ultimately
happening was
i associated productivity and doing with
success
and obviously you need to do to be
successful but like that's not the end
state um and i had to unlearn that in a
big way
so lots of you know personal growth um
and i think on also a really personal
note i don't know if this is
particularly true to women but it's it's
been a theme a lot of conversations i've
had is i was really disassociated from
my body
you know i i had worked so hard i
um also i think as a woman in the
workplace as a young woman
i had to almost like pretend to not be a
woman and not be feminine and just
ignore that
identity and so all of a sudden i was
like at a concert and i just like
had somatic experiences i was like oh
i'm feeling the music in my body i'm
like there's information here there's a
gut feeling
and i i really reconnected with
intuition and gut feeling and
what that meant from a physical
component which then kind of
was both very personal but then got me
so much more connected to what i'm doing
today and
and realizing how many women um because
of external pressures
have been taught to normalize pain or to
normalize discomfort
um and so you know i was back in la and
i connected with a friend of mine from
high school
who had just had a baby and you know she
was telling me everything she was going
on in her body and
this happens to everyone but like her
abs were separated her neck and shoulder
were killing her
she was leaking she couldn't control her
bladder she was having painful sex
this is a woman of privilege who has
some of the best insurance in the
country
and that was her reality and so you know
we started talking she's a friend from
high school now my co-founder
um and she basically googled around
desperation
and found a physical therapist and was
dramatically healed and we started just
talking and we're like wait
this is the standard of care in france
like you get pt when you break your
pinky but not when you deliver a child
through your vagina or through an
invasive c-section like what's what's
wrong here
um and why hasn't this taken off and
that really kicked off
now the journey that is origin so you're
discovering this whole opportunity
through uh sort of a self-discovery um
experience and uh it starts with
connecting
in the mind and body but it's
discovering that there's this whole
i don't know if it's taboo subject or if
it's just
you know it's it's an industry that how
do how do you
you know identify that that people
aren't working on this because like you
mentioned
now that you mention it it seems so
ridiculous that
people are getting physical therapy when
when anything when
this uh the slightest discomfort but
something like giving like childbirth
which obviously is a man
i'll never understand the pain but but
doing something as traumatic to the body
as it is
you don't really get that treatment how
do you explain that people aren't
trying to solve it other than perhaps
origin
you know i think there's a few things so
one there's obviously
a lot of gender bias in medicine and
systemic in this country so like until
the 90s
we were using men's bodies to study
issues that only impacted women or
primarily impacted women so you could
actually do research on ovarian cancer
in men right so like this is 90s like
1990s
so we have just this deep systemic
gender
bias in medicine that's well documented
you know and it extends everything it's
women are less likely to have their pain
taken seriously they're more likely to
you know have heart attacks being
misdiagnosed just
end to end women have had to become
bigger advocates for their own care
um so this that's just messed up but
like that's the fundamental reality
i think we also have um what was
historically
probably stigma or taboo subjects around
pelvic health or vaginas or you know
like we would just associate anything
pelvic oriented around
either fertility or sex which are things
that are not often talked about in
public discourse
although that's changing um and then i
think there's just structural reasons
that hasn't happened before
so um we're one of the only and i can
tell you a little bit what we do but
please most of the people who do what we
do don't take insurance
and so you know you think about like
mainstream access
really has to be affordable for this to
take off um
and and at our at our core just to kind
of level set
so origin is is providing physical
therapy for women and mothers and
we are treating these incredibly common
but often overlooked issues that impact
women
often around pregnancy and postpartum
but like throughout our lives so
whether that's painful sex or you're an
athlete and you know you're doing
crossfit and you can't control your
bladder all the way through menopause
and you're having you know your muscles
are weakening and you need more support
and pt is actually the first line
treatment for all of these issues that
women experience
um but as we said you know there's some
supply side issues there's some payer
problems and
just the cultural the cultural norms um
and i think what was
really interesting for us is as we
started digging into this early days
the investors weren't there yet too so
investors used to say
fertility is women's health and they'd
be like okay but
what about everything after fertility
like you know you have 50
of the population experiencing these
issues and because
all the best companies at the time were
in the fertility space that's what like
the market associated with women's
health
um and that was you know even just two
years ago today
i just i can't even tell you it's like
an explosion of creativity in women's
health right now
everything from cpg and menopause and
pregnancy and it's
it's very different but a few years ago
um that wasn't the case and it's
probably because there weren't as many
women vcs
you know frankly who were really you
were pitching to mainly men
yeah huh that's interesting so so talk
to me a little bit more about
about this boom that you're experiencing
because until now it sounded like
you know you almost stumbled upon this
this new market and the opportunity
that's
it's obviously making a huge impact on
on women's lives
and and really really an important space
but you're also talking about the fact
that you you know there's there is an
explosion not just that you're working
on but there
there's a lot of creativity in this
space and you're attributing a lot to of
it to what to
female in vc positions where they're
also interested in seeing these types of
products but
is that the main reason you think
i don't know if it's the main reason but
i think it's just like a perfect storm
that was you know kind of putting the
blinders on and then you also just have
to think about this cultural
cycle that we were in so let's say you
gave birth
and then your body is a wreck and then
you go to your doctor six weeks later is
the only touch point you have and then
you don't see your doctor for another
year after that
no one is helping you feel better and so
that normalizes pain right and so
every woman who's been through that
cycle before is just taught that that's
just the way it is
there's no real solution like i'm gonna
have to pee my pants for the rest of my
life or sex is always gonna hurt or
just right so but like if
that's
the psychology then it's really hard to
see and say oh
like there's actually a real solution um
without either saying something was
wrong with me for not finding it or like
what's wrong with the medical system
um i think people are waking up to that
in a big way so
i don't i don't think it's just you know
vcs you have me too you have like so
many trends that have
have shifted the conversation and i
think even culturally now people are
just far more open on instagram
about these issues themselves so um
you're just seeing a lot of people
it's almost like an awakening like no
i'm not gonna live with this anymore and
we have
so many patients um who are coming in
and it's just really intergenerational
like
someone is coming in uh maybe postpartum
and they're bringing their younger
sister
this has truly happened they're bringing
their younger sister who's an athlete
and their mom is going through menopause
and it's like no none of us are going to
go through this anymore
because like why would we i love that i
love that
it's a revolution yeah it really sounds
like that
what are some you know tips that you
that you can think of and
you know in retrospect about identifying
interesting market opportunities and you
know these
these hidden hidden markets that perhaps
that today we either
are not comfortable talking about or
they're just you know
underserved in general
yeah you know i wish there was like
here's the formula for uh
for finding you know new markets i i
think it it does require obviously
you know just having some of your own
intuition expertise but
i think you know part of it is i always
think about this framework
there's a lot of people talk about
product market fit but i think a lot
about
product market capital fit so you have
to have both like
the product that's serving the right
people but then also a way to fund that
and you see a lot of companies
who are like let's say trying to go get
vc capital that are not necessarily
going to scale in that way or
um you know just the conversation around
how those three have come together i
think have been missing the mark
um but but i would just say you know
there's some early signals on how
industries are changing so let's say
just looking at healthcare
healthcare 1.0 around digital health was
like let's do what was happening
in person and make it like better and
digital and that was one medical
and all these other companies who just
like brought it up to the consumer age
and now it's like
what is the real product digital first
solution that's going to actually be a
game changer
for the patient um and so i think you'll
probably see similar cycles in other
industries where
first it's just about like let's just
make it better and now it's actually
let's make it new
and far more effective than we could
have ever imagined
i love that karine thank you so much for
watching the time to do this this was uh
inspiring and so interesting and and it
sounds like what you're doing is really
a hugely impactful and has and has a
positive impact on so many women and i
can't wait to see where origin
physical therapy grows and takes you
before we end this i want to
ask you the most difficult question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
so it was a hard one i you gave me a
little hint that this was gonna happen
so i had a minute to think about it but
um
i think the three words would be uh
creative curious
and unstoppable i love that yes
okay finally i think this was this is
the first episode in about 300 episodes
where somebody said unstoppable and i
love that word
it's uh i love it we're just going to go
amazing i'm so grateful thank you so so
much uh
stay safe stay healthy and i can't wait
to share this with the world
thank you